Eric Palacios from Eric Palacios and  Associates shares what to know what you  need to know when you have the right of  way while driving in today's legal  minute  hi I'm Eric Palacios welcome to the  legal minute today's question is how do  I know if I have the right-of-way while  driving if you're driving on a straight  road with no traffic lights or signs you  have the right of way Vehicles turning  into the road you're on have to yield to  you if you reach an intersection with no  traffic signs or non-operating traffic  lights the first vehicle to reach the  intersection has the right-of-way if two  or more Vehicles reach the intersection  at the same time then the one on the  right has the right-of-way this has been  the legal minute if you have any legal  questions you can call us at  702-444-7777  give Eric Palacios and Associates a call  or visit their website at Eric  palacioslaw.com we'll be right back on  Las Vegas now